sur l'air de jeu aujourd'hui déserte
décompresse ensanglanté témoigne du
dramatique accident qui s'est produit
hier après midi
en ce dimanche ensoleillé des dizaines
d'enfants s'amuse dont un petit garçon
de 10 ans qui joue auto moment il est
environ 16 heures quand un chien échappe
à la surveillance de ses maîtres
l'animal attaque l'enfant lui causant de
profondes morsures au visage
immédiatement le garçon est hospitalisé
d'urgence en chirurgie à l'hôpital de
nevers
il va passer trois heures au bloc
opératoire et ses jours ne sont pas en
danger
il y a quand même à noter c'est très
important je trouve quatre adultes sur
place qui ont maîtrisé l'animal est
vraiment je les remercie du courage
qu'ils ont eut parce que c'est pas
forcément simple à mon ce petit enfant a
été très gravement blessé
je pense que le traumatisme va être
important et il aura besoin de beaucoup
des déchets beaucoup de beaucoup
d'empathie pour lui et sa famille c'est
un chien comme celui ci de la race des
bull-terriers qui a attaqué l'enfant
contrairement à son cousin le pitbull il
est classée en troisième catégorie
considérée aussi inoffensifs qu'un
caniche ou un labrador pour les
spécialistes du comportement canin cette
catégorisation n'est pas pertinente pour
prévenir ce genre d'accident plus de
danger avec lui lui faut vendéen qu'avec
avec le staff
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire pour que
ce type d'accident ne se produise plus
alors déjà je supprimerai cook et
catégorie et je créerai interné pour
détention de chiens on n'est jamais à
l'abri et tant que les maîtres n'auront
pas les informations requises
ça arrive encore malheureusement alors
on rejette toujours la faute sur le
chien alors que c'est pas le fia c'est
la mauvaise information des maîtres qui
devrait éduquer appréhendé par les
services vétérinaires le mon terrier a
été ausculté âgé d'un an et demi il
avait déjà causé des morsures par le
passé ses maîtres se sont rendus
d'eux-mêmes à la gendarmerie
et ils ont demandé l'euthanasie de leur
animal